[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un palais renaissance situé sur
les hauteurs de rome un palais florentin
voulue par les médicis est racheté par
napoléon une maison des arts l'académie
de france qui surplombe la ville
éternelle un peu de france en italie la
villa médicis veille sur la ville depuis
des siècles et accueille chaque année
des pensionnaires qui est sur le volet
vous savez ici c'est un bouillon de
culture en tous les cas c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on veut être c'est un
laboratoire de création c'est un lieu un
peu particulier d'ailleurs qui confronte
des missions parfois un peu antagonistes
conserver du patrimoine et être au coeur
à la pointe de la création contemporaine
un certain nombre de créateurs célèbres
sont passés par parricide et des
musiciens berlioz debussy des
architectes garnier des peintres ingres
des sculpteurs panetière
l'errance
chercher se trompe et fait partie du
chemin on offre ici une espèce de luxe
particulier au 21ème siècle qui est un
temple de recherche attentes des
intéressés onze mois de création dans un
cadre vertigineux l'idée n'est pas
nouvelle elle date de l'académie de rome
a voulu par louis xiv mais depuis la
maison se réinvente les arts
apparaissent ici désormais dans leur
variété 16 pensionnaires sont là en
résidence pour onze mois ils étaient
plus de 600 candidats parmi eux kaouther
adimi après quatre romans la résidence
tombe à pic pour lui permettre d'écrire
son nouveau projet c'est la première
idée que j'ai eue de romans en fait et
ce n'était pas le bon moment pendant
très longtemps c'est devenu le bon
moment aujourd'hui et pour ce roman en
particulier j'avais besoin de m'éloigner
de mon quotidien j'avais besoin de temps
d'un temps qui ne serait pas un temps
que je volerais entre un travail entre
plein plein plein d'activités plein de
choses à faire qui faisait que je
n'avais pas cette possibilité de me
consacrer à temps plein à l'écriture et
c'est ce que m'a permis la villa médicis
faire un pas de côté c'est également le
souhaitent de noémie godard architecte
d'intérieur pendant 15 ans elle a décidé
de prendre de la hauteur et présenter un
projet à la ville à un livre sur les
intérieurs et sur ce qu'ils disent de
nous une enquête à travers les âges à
travers l'italie et à travers rome
évidemment preuve c'est très inspirant
c'est un livre ouvert en fait de
l'histoire de l'architecturé de
l'histoire de l'art des sciences c'est
un terrain de jeu exceptionnel sa porte
en soi
tout plein de situations construites
existantes
sur des périodes historiques très large
du coup ça un terreau expérimental
vraiment fabuleux pour poser ses
questions de l'intérieur un rom
inspirante et rome inspiré une ville
sans cesse réinventée par les
pensionnaires de la villa la ville
éternelle qui infuse peu à peu dans le
travail des pensionnaires et permettent
à chacun de prendre une nouvelle
dimension parce que c'est important pour
pour les penseurs ici d'établir
avec la ville de rome et rob zombie qui
sait être est habitué à l'idée de l'art
de la culture en général et donc
ici sempé une espace de pour manifester
d'une façon naturelle et spontanée la
créativité
créez donc expliquer donner à réfléchir
expérimenté aussi c'est le projet de
noémie l'architecte d'intérieur ce matin
là dans quelques heures des milliers de
roumains seront ici pour assister à la
nuit blanche un rendez vous fort de
l'année culturelle
comme ça s'est construit en fait une
narration
appuyé d'iconographie mais qui du coup
porte des comment dire déjà des
histoires et surtout des relations entre
les bâtiments les usages et ceux qui
habitaient ça c'est le tout la
thématique sur laquelle je travaille en
fait c'est finalement comme une grande
fresque qui vient d'être apposée sur le
mur donc on va voir un peu comment à
l'heure
elle vit avec le lieu
quelques semaines seulement après
l'arrivée les pensionnaires d'une
première expérience une introspection
aussi sur leur travail voilà c'est fini
là cette fois c'est fini
[Musique]
à quelques mètres de là la tension monte
d'un cran le bouillonnant compositeur
catalan rectorat répète il est venu ici
pour composer un opéra inspiré de
l'oeuvre de pasolini mais après avoir
collaboré avec marie ndiaye ou adapter
les bienveillantes de jonah table little
à l'opéra il a décidé pour l'occasion
d'accompagner un compte créé par
kaouther adimi l'autre pensionnaire
on a répété ensemble pendant une semaine
c'est une très belle expérience et
kaouther adimi en matière très connu les
gens extraordinaires que je voulais
composé aime la musique pour son compte
aussi pour voir comment ma musique se
développe développe une sainte anne rose
un mystère
[Musique]
la villa peut s'ouvrir aux romains le
conte musical de kaouther adimi le banc
aux mises en musique par hector pareils
sa compagnie masante a créé on reçoit un
bel accueil
la nuit blanche ne fait que commencer
les pensionnaires comme kauter hector ou
noémie prennent très vite des allures
d'ambassadeur de la culture et de la
création made in france au milieu des
moulages plutôt académique des oeuvres
plus contemporaines
projection de déambulation à rome en
hommage à pasolini et son mât roma
installations lectures conférences
performances artistiques mais aussi
gustatives toutes les disciplines sont
là ou presque le rendez vous cette année
a attiré plus de 5000 personnes et
réunit artistes français et public
romain dans une rome pour l'occasion
devenu comme incandescente